holiday weekend travel or rather the
lack of it for the first time in 20
years triple-a is not issuing a travel
forecast for the Memorial Day weekend
they say they just don't have the
economic data to make a prediction and
the CDC is warning
remember travel can increase the chance
of getting infected or spreading the
virus but nevertheless some people are
still taking the risk and going out Kris
Van Cleave has more the great or perhaps
not so great Memorial Day getaway has
started Airlines report a bump in
bookings but American still expects to
be down about 80 percent from last year
if it had been a month ago or two months
ago I wouldn't have done anything after
being home since March 19th
Thomas Bowman is flying from Chicago to
Fort Lauderdale to see friends at some
point we're gonna have to go back to
life
however defined and I thought this was a
reasonable step they've been isolated
I've been isolated but a recent Harris
poll found 95 percent of Americans say
because of the coronavirus Memorial Day
is too soon to take a trip when the
annual rolling to remember motorcycle
ride honoring veterans in DC was
canceled Carol Hebert decided to stay
home in Michigan for the first time in
20 years triple-a did not offer a
Memorial Day travel forecast but expects
fewer people to hit the road than the
record low of 31 million back in 2009
still health officials worried about
scenes like these
crowds on a Jersey Shore boardwalk and
this raucous street party in Florida
last weekend Florida Highway Patrol will
be fully staffed this Memorial Day
holiday watching for drunk or distracted
drivers and of course for speeders the
co vid 19 restrictions are being lifted
in Florida therefore we are expecting
more motorists to come out of the house
so we're ready for if it's a
traditional-style
weekend with a lot of motorists on the
road and we're ready for if it's maybe a
little bit more calm Chesapeake Bay
Bridge back behind us is really the
gateway to Maryland's now reopened
beaches and in a typical year you would
see traffic build throughout the day
triple-a says if you are going to travel
for Memorial Day weekend do your
homework know what's open and know about
whatever state rules are still in effect
for example neighboring Delaware still
requires visitors to self quarantine for
14 days Gail Chris thank you very much